je commence à faire des cauchemars j'y
rêve même que j'ai un titre de séjour la
nuit je me réveille dans les rêves
alors que dans la vraie vie je n'ai pas
de l'ehpad et d'études des saisons
j'ai reçu un message d'accusé de
réception et la partie des ces
moments-là jusqu'aujourd'hui qui n'est
pas encore libéré tôt
le visage s'est passé
[Musique]
je peux rien faire comme une démarche
administrative je ne vais pas chercher
un petit travail pour survivre figurez
vous que je suis pas boursiers je ne
peux rien faire
j'avais également quelques-uns location
par rapport à mon logement
ça a été coupée donc tout ça je n'ai
rien prévu c'est très compliqué c'est
très compliqué donc la g g doit attendre
dépendent de la généreuse de la
générosité des le cousin des mes frères
il faut que j'aie les appels j'ai les
harcèlent vous leur dis bah ouais moi
quelque chose parce que c'est compliqué
sinon j'avais cru et donc cesser c'est
comme ça qu'il faudrait définir pour
pour les mots ça c'est ma valise que
j'ai déjà préparé il ya de cela un mois
je j'espérais voyager pour aller voir ma
mère n'est pas en bonne santé
et ça me fait mal que j'ai vu cette
situation à la fin de mon master parce
que c'est déterminant
j'ai le projet d'aller aux thèses et
pour aller en terre il faut avoir de
bons résultats j'ai toujours bien
travaillé
maintenant avec social avec cette
situation je ne sais pas ce qui serait à
la hauteur parce que je laisse la
planter devant le livre je travaille pas
comme d'habitude donc si c'est tout
l'ensemble c'est un blocage
intellectuelle morale
en novembre cette situation
l'accumulation des demandes a fait qu'un
certain nombre d'étudiants qui se sont
manifestés ils ont eu raison parce
qu'ils n'avaient pas cette attestation
provisoire
un message a été envoyé aux préfectures
mi-novembre et en une dizaine de jours à
peu près les attestations ont été
délivrés aux étudiants
[Musique]
quand la demande est complète
il ya des préfectures qui le lendemain
de la demande ont déjà répondu disent
vous avez un titre de séjour pour
l'année prochaine pour les prochaines
années
et donc il n'y a pas de document
provisoire c'est l'intérêt aussi c'est
d'éviter que les étudiants passent une
partie sur une année universitaire avec
mon provisoire qui doit renouveler en
préfecture qu'elle doit prendre rendez
vous tout ça c'est fini je dépose en
ligne ma demande 20 25 jours après en
moyenne j'obtiens la réponse le fait que
j'ai un titre de séjour désormais
suffisamment vite pour que le titre
actuel de l'étudiant ne soit pas expiré
malheureusement à ce moment là j'avais
déjà partout mon contrat d'apprentissage
parce que l'entreprise ne pouvait pas
attendre que je reçois de l'attestation
de prolongateur étant donné que je n'ai
aucune nouvelle sur la date à laquelle à
les recevoir
donc ils ont tout bonnement rompu le
contrat la date butoir pour en trouver
au niveau de l'université l'est pas
c'est parce que c'était début décembre
là j'ai demandé à repasser en initial
pour ne pas perdre mon année
tous ces étudiants là comment est-ce que
le gouvernement va les dédommager nous
ce qu'on demande c'est qu'il y ait des
réponses concrètes à la fois on permette
enfin aux étudiants étrangers d'accéder
aux aides sociales aux bourses
d'abord mais aussi aux aides d'urgence
faire si le gouvernement souhaite mettre
en place une aide exceptionnelle de le
faire mais il n'empêche que ça résoudra
pas le problème sur le temps long parce
que le souci il est aussi là il est
qu'il faut pouvoir avoir une aide qui
n'est pas seulement une aide ponctuelle
six étudiants ils ont besoin de lunettes
de long terme quand on a perdu un emploi
on n'a pas simplement besoin de
compenser le mois de novembre nous a dit
c'est dur d'avoir 20 ans en 2020 1 c'est
dur d'être étudiants étrangers en france
en 2020
on
[Musique]